got the animal fries yeah you want some
dog
animal style dog style fries yeah
too soon
i don't know i got it earlier why
doesn't anybody care
chad's saying it's a [ __ ]
maybe my hopes are are
easily
shattered me maybe maybe i have too much
faith in people but
i i would think that even the trash bag
humans that stream on ip2
would care at least enough to make sure
that a dog is okay
not worry about snitching and by the way
what are you snitching on alice i don't
think anybody's gonna shoot baked i
don't think
i don't think you're gonna catch a
receipt in the streets
because uh because you snitched on alice
i don't think alice has any connections
to the [ __ ]
the training bloods or whatever
like i don't get it i would be the most
hated person in irl i'd be calling the
police right now if i knew where these
people were
if i was with these people streaming i'd
be like oh okay
yeah no no no i'm with you man you don't
want to snatch and i would have ducked
off
the minute they stopped at that gas
station i would have been like beep
boop boop yeah i uh i need to report uh
a case of animal cruelty
as well as uh for people aiding and
abetting
uh the torture of an animal and covering
it up um
probably i would say uh
probably animal cruelty and then easily
three charges of accessory after the
fact
boom it's easy um
it's easy to do that and i would have
done it and slept like a baby
like [ __ ] up [ __ ] the whole like stop
and don't snitch
i would have called the cops i would
have had them all thrown in jail and i
would have went home and i would have
slept like a [ __ ]
baby i would have been out like a log
would have called the [ __ ] front desk
at the hotel and been like hey do me a
favor
uh put me down for late check out cause
daddy's sleeping like a log tonight
um again i mean who cares even if you
didn't go home even if you didn't care
whatever you still just
you just make arrangements for the dog
to be fed that's all
you don't even have to go home you just
go hey take care of the dog for a couple
days
somebody said dude bake just said i'm so
glad my pets are alive like this is
funny to them
they keep saying call the fire or police
department again
what's your take on that whole situation
uh
well don't call peter no help
what did they say uh yeah ask for a
[ __ ] expert and like yeah how long
does a
dog live and um they said is it an
emergency
i'm a volunteer like [ __ ] you doing here
then um
so i yeah called fire department and
[ __ ]
yeah or no i didn't call the fire
department um i think
a fire department would help maybe
though um
you got these people that you're on your
account how do i switch accounts
click click the person up up
yeah and then you can switch there
um so yeah i think i think
i missed it is a good point not up until
tomorrow he's asking
chicken andy for advice a 21 year old
junkie
what do you think i should do that's a
good point
to live 72 hours yes
okay it was okay it was last fed on
monday
last bed monday yeah that's that's what
i'm saying so
the days it's not been fed is tuesday
wednesday thursday that's
that's three days but the dad said he he
gave it
twice his amount of food but we don't
know about the water we don't know
and alice said oh like it can drink from
the toilets but then when she called her
dad he's like no
the dad's like no i locked it in the
cage so
obviously it can't drink toilet water in
a cage so
i think she should call her dad and ask
how much water was given to it
that's not [ __ ] good but
i know like i don't feel good about that
and i but here's maybe you could talk to
her because every time i try to talk to
her she thinks i'm trolling her she's
like stop like leave me alone and i'm
like no i'm like
genuinely um concerned
fire department but then the
dog will probably get it but it'll
they're all complicit in this
karma is already coming for you gonna
char back bdw
how does it feel everyone on the right
will be ecstatic when andy knocks you
out in the fight
ralpher toward america first everyone is
cringing at the [ __ ] you are doing at 30
years old grow up fatty
i've never [ __ ] had my pets you know
like that's a that's a whole new
situation for me
and it's not my situation you know i
mean yeah like i would
i would i would ask uh
a department like fire police of that
little area
like if it was ever i personally
yeah everything with these people
everything is this is an easily solvable
problem
this is an easily solvable problem the
reason why everybody is so stomped by
this is because they're trying to figure
out a way
to get the dog out that doesn't involve
getting anyone in trouble
or getting arrested or getting allison
or breaking something it's going to cost
her money trying to get back in that
like
like that's all it is they just want to
they want something that won't cost any
money
and won't result in any charges and
won't get anybody
they don't want to snitch on anybody so
it's so they're all
i want to point this out and i want
everyone to save tonight's night wave
as a [ __ ] as a case study in case any
of these
suckers think that they're going to get
away with this
i'm going to make it my [ __ ] business
to make sure
that baked alaska and alice and dope
district
and lols and anybody else who knew about
this [ __ ] dog for this amount of time
and did nothing about it
i want to make sure that every single
one of them is arrested before christmas
every single one of them and i don't
care if it's a misdemeanor
i don't care if it's a class f felony
that's basically a glorified misdemeanor
i don't get i don't care if the charges
get dropped
these suckers are going to a [ __ ]
jail cell i will make it my [ __ ]
business
there's there's just a limit to what i
can take and this dog [ __ ] is
the longer they sit around and go uh oh
maybe if you call like the county maybe
the or
whatever oh i'll tell you what what if
you call
the cable company right and you tell
them
hey my modem's not working right
but also when they get there go oh you
know what it started working again
but while you're there could you feed my
dog because i don't want to go to jail
like they're literally just oh what if
you i'll tell you what what if you
called
a mobile car detailer and got the mobile
car detailer to drive out
and then when they get there go oh
there's no car but i'll pay you like you
were gonna wash your car but can you
break in my house and feed my dog
like every just call police just call
the police that's all that's all you got
to do
so now since none of these people want
to do that
i want to see every single one of these
people get arrested
for accessory after the fact which is
exactly what the [ __ ]
the charges would be depending on what
the state the state is or wherever it is
there's always a charge
for for even misdemeanor sometimes a
felony
uh obstruction it's not always
obstruction though sometimes it's aiding
in a bedding
accessory some kind of charge like that
every single one of these [ __ ]
is officially complicit
once an hour went by and nothing has
been done
you are now all complicit okay
listen i love royce royce is like a
brother to me
but if royce was knowingly and callously
and evilly just torturing an
animal right now or starving it to death
and he knew what he was doing and he
just had no
didn't give a [ __ ] and there was no
other way
to save the dog i'd call the cops on
that [ __ ]
i'm sorry but you know what i mean like
if you're just like yeah whatever [ __ ]
it who cares
i'll if she's dead she's dead i'd be
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
so yeah man this is just [ __ ] man
it's not it's literally not yeah it's my
fault
okay but okay we are my point is we are
where we are now what is the best
like would it be a locksmith fire
department would it be
you probably have the cops and the cops
will like watch the locksmith guy
or i mean you could probably trust the
locksmith like just pay him actually
see what i mean you see what i mean they
don't want the cops involved because
they know
because they know because they [ __ ]
know
they know it's like a 10 second call i
don't know that was a 10 second call and
i started calling another locksmith
she started screaming at me so i was
like yeah that's weird
did you see that if literally anybody
else was there
your honor i want this preserved on the
night wave record
baked alaska baked alaska
tim gianette just made himself
an accessory to animal cruelty
we let the macing [ __ ] go we let all the
other [ __ ] go
i am not letting this
go i want baked alaska thrown
in a [ __ ] jail cell now
now now now now
not later [ __ ] now
she can be their friend yeah but he
doesn't have a key
is the only problem exactly he was gonna
check on it but he doesn't have a key
that's what i'm saying and then you just
verify on the phone she's just like yes
this is my information this is my house
i just need
and then she could even be like you can
literally watch them gonna feed the dog
let them out real quick
and then you can go on your way and by
the way for future record just so you
all know so all of you understand this
because i care about you guys if you're
ever in a situation like this and
somebody's life is at stake or an
animal's life is at stake or something
is in you know something like that
somebody's missing
if you are caught in any manner at any
point
saying something to the effect of uh we
don't need to get the cops involved in
this
you have officially legally
made yourself complicit in whatever cri
you are you are displaying knowledge of
illegality
and you are displaying a an active
desire to want to inhibit the work of
police department
right there when you go wow we don't
need the cops just do the locks
you that means you know something's
going the [ __ ] on
how do i uninstall going blizzard
do i just go to uninstall or you could
just type in
control panel control
so instead of just calling the police
this [ __ ] just set some poor
maintenance worker to walk into her
dog's rotting
corpse in a day or two what an absolute
deficit of a human being
seriously he's just gonna walk in with a
ladder and some pain and be like
the old meal
oh [ __ ] if it's not too expensive
hey merch real donno here sorry about
the stream
i'm a known drake poster blowing up
please alice is blowing up she necked
her dog
and now she's gonna bring down the whole
stream shout out right away
radio that's hilarious
um look i i uh
i'm not look i'm going to say this that
i
i certainly um
i certainly don't think that people
should be bullied to the point of i
don't believe that
but in the case of alice
i would be willing to overlook that sin
with people you know what i mean like i
don't think i would
you know most of the time i go jesus you
picked on them until they jumped i would
be okay with it
i'm just i i'm i despise this little
garbage pail kid
she's a soulless greasy-haired
promiscuous manipulative little
[ __ ] cup that is a
real thing i think did you get the email
let me check
[Music]
if it's not too expensive didn't donny
sign the preventing animal cruelty and
torture act making this a federally
punishable crime
god willing but yes i agree with you
about sammy sammy would have gotten the
dog
and you know what sammy probably would
have fed the dog
some kind of like spoiled food that she
fished out of a dumpster and the dog
might have gotten sick
but you know what it would have been
forgivable you know why because sammy's
would
but she means well and that's all that
matters
sammy could have given the dog food
poisoning and killed it
like by giving it trash food and i'd be
less angry at sammy right now
because sammy's a [ __ ] and just doesn't
know any better and she's like what i
don't know i just thought pork that was
in a dumpster for three days was fine
you know like you'd go all right you
know you're an idiot and you did kill
the dog but i can't
it's like when a kid does something dumb
you know like remember the scene in the
wire
when uh when the the mayor came home and
his kid had stuffed the sandwich in the
vcr
and he got really pissed for a second
but then he stopped himself because the
kid was like oh i was saving you a piece
of the sandwich and the kid's like three
and then you're like yeah yeah you
ruined the vcr but you're a cute little
[ __ ] you meant well
you know what i mean unlock it
for 125. you can save your dog and i'll
pay for it
you don't know that though like
i'm not saying i know or you know i'm
just saying we all don't know
and your dog is blowing up
you would have you have to get blowing
up we need a real owner and send a
picture of your id
um can you see if vinnie would be able
to
meet up
i don't like inconveniencing my friends
[ __ ] yeah but this is an emergency so
like
this is really [ __ ] up that you have
your dog starving in a cage
my dad put her in the cage wow chicken
andy coming out with a [ __ ] piece of
has a piece of his soul left by the way
chicken andy kind of taken control here
of all i mean they need a friend
i'm i'm stunned here
and my social security i'm really
stunned
that the voice of consciousness the the
voice of conscience
and the voice of reason
is chicken andy he's literally been the
one going you should probably you really
should call locksmith or
the [ __ ] like he's that guy he's also
a train wreck and he's also been in
situations
where he said to break into places so he
has enough experience as a piece of [ __ ]
to go
yeah you call a locksmith or you get
somebody to break into the
second story window or whatever like you
chicken handy when he's sober he's
actually like
and then she starts talking [ __ ] he goes
no what's [ __ ] up is leaving your dog
to starve in a cage you're dumb
like holy [ __ ] well i can chicken andy
his
soul is coming alive to
see my dog yeah because the dad said
last time is fed
it's in a cage was monday that means
tuesday wednesday
three days no food and water tomorrow's
friday
turns friday
yeah and i even said i'll pit yeah
because i just wanna yeah you made a lot
of donuts
oh no i mean i want her dog to be okay
i'll say this chicken does seem to be
fairly tolerable when he's not all
[ __ ] up like he does seem like
he does seem like the least hateable
person in that house right now
i don't know can you try calling
emergency maintenance again then or
something
i'm just trying to help you like this
looks really bad
you okay yeah i'll call them again
oh my god like she can't even be
all bothered so vin let's just for the
record vinnie is down
if we get locksmith no he's not he has
work he has obviously he just said he
was down
he said he was down and you're like oh
i'd rather just talk [ __ ]
don't worry she doesn't have obligations
for her own dog okay she's a
the dog is fine
well i'm like i mean i'm even offering
to like pay for [ __ ]
all righty
i know that's [ __ ] up that's kind of
dude
i feel like chicken andy out of all
these people would legitimately
if you got him off drugs put him in a
ged program and got him away from other
streamers
he's the one that would be more likely
to actually become a
normal human being no you're [ __ ]
doing everything that's fine i know like
i feel bad as [ __ ] like i'm just trying
to like
it just seems like every like solution i
have you know what it is
you know what chicken andy is basically
uh name and name and bryce from
the wire chicken is naaman from the wire
if he got adopted by a cop and went to a
nice school like he would just totally
straighten out
it's alternate universe andy
witness everyone the next casey anthony
alice to go clubbing because she wants
to have fun
she is a horrible girl she should never
have children
she would rather around than save a life
i will receive an email when they follow
up
will that be tomorrow morning or
right you're not sure okay
um that's what i'm saying i don't think
anything's gonna be
okay uh taken care of tonight
okay so yeah that's what i thought like
it
unless you literally talk to someone
who's like i'm going to your house now
like
no you can't rely on them so i say let's
do the locksmith i'll pay for it
you won't be financially oh hero
look at that he can call himself the
hero or whatever you need um
and i'm texting the locksmith
your number
no he already said he would so let's he
lit i heard i heard him
i heard it did you hear him hang on it's
getting chicken turning kind of warm
we heard him he literally said yeah
that's fine like 30. we can go get more
flicker but um yeah it's 9 30. i'll
drive
hey alice let me see your phone
um okay so i told the locksmith to text
you
i just want to help you out okay
wait he calls me minnie
hey what's up
hey this is dr philippe
[Music]
let me just make sure it matches up
[Music]
[Music]
see you'll be able to sleep
now you can help the dog and just relax
by the way i love this ip2 community
they'll [ __ ] swat people and swat
people and swat people but then when
there's an
actual crime they're nowhere to be found
you notice that
they only like to swat people when it's
funny when it's when it's a funny
thing but you notice they'll never
actually legitimately call the police
unbelievable is this chick worth your
reputation the guy asked what reputation
does baked have left
other than nick fuentes actual fanboys
who likes
baked alaska just wait a minute did the
pizza bake
you were getting pissed off at me
whatever do the [ __ ] up dude oh boy
no figure it out dude i will not shut
the [ __ ] up
that's super fun okay shut up no yes
no yeah shut up don't barely eat that
but
five out of five sales we got insane we
got you're going to say
yes you're insane i'm hoping you're
[ __ ] the [ __ ] girl you got alex
[Music]
situation of your dog almost dying like
that i'm sorry this is dark
this girl is sick look at this [ __ ] no
bro like dope
this [ __ ] is
[Music]
honestly i'm literally not even a girl
let him suck your dick and then kick him
out
i've dated i've told you guys before
that i've dated
uh not one but two women
that have had the dark triad which are
the three
absolute um
sort of narcissism-based personality
disorders that you can have
it's machiavellianism um
um sociopathy
and something else but it's like the
three words it's called the dark triad
and when you have it you're
it's strongly advised that those people
that you not have
any contact with people who have that
it's incurable
and they're [ __ ] for life and they
will ruin everything they touch and i've
dated two women like that
neither of those women bpd thank you yes
neither of those women
were as bad as this girl here like baked
is in
for a hell of a time okay i'm just
saying
that yeah let's keep it transparent to
the chat
that's what it is narcissism
machiavellianism and psychopathy thank
you those are the three if
you have those three it's it is it's the
sk
thank you no no uh draven williams got
it right narcissism machiavellianism
and psychopathy and when per somebody
has all three it's called the dark triad
and it's like being
i mean it's like being a super villain
that's the craziest scariest somebody
can be i want your dog to be okay
like i'm worried as [ __ ] so am i why do
you think i was crying and freaking the
[ __ ] out
i know but just take this feedback says
i married a dark triad i'm surprised i
haven't kissed you
[Music]
like when i was helping you you were
stopping me
yeah no you did help me like the most
recent one i dated that had the dark
triad traits
i dude i'm not gonna lie i'm still
[ __ ] up from that girl
like i don't care about her and i'm not
like attached to her but like
like i'm scared i'm still emotionally
flinchy because of her being
disrespectful to me
i'm being disrespectful that last girl
actually made so you'll
[ __ ] get the big impact on who i am
today
that you need this this d live man
no if you if you wouldn't let me call
the locksmith the first time it would
have
she's not even cute bro but this girl
was foot
this alice girl looks like a garbage
pail kid
baked is going through all this stress
to stick his dick in a
five like that's gross